argentina is adopting bitcoin and the
lightning network at an insane pace what
am i talking about well first it's
important to understand that argentina
is in a dire economic situation they've
been plagued with economic turmoil and
uncertainty inflation will reach 55 this
year gdp will contract by 12 percent
it's been a currency crisis since the
central bank was founded and half the
population is already living in poverty
all coming from jack muller's now of
course people know that the bitcoins
lightning network has been growing at a
incredible pace it continues to hit
all-time high after all-time high across
multiple metrics here you can see the
bitcoin capacity of public channels
growing up and to the right exactly what
you would want to see when you're
looking for adoption now strike which
uses the bitcoin lightning network has
been growing in argentina they saw over
a hundred thousand people download and
adopt the app in just two weeks
we've got this quote here from jack
mullers where he said we're just
monitoring argentina seeing how it's
going and we're going to launch in
hopefully 50 countries this year 100
countries this year i don't know but
argentina was wildly successful within
the first few weeks we got over 100 000
downloads and registrations and users
signed up
now of course what we know is whether
we're talking about places like el
salvador argentina or somewhere else
around the world these countries that
are in dire economic situations bitcoin
ends up being the release valve people
don't trust their governments they don't
trust their central banks they simply
want money that can't be debased by
anyone they want permissionless ability
to access monetary value they want to
send and receive money without anyone
else being able to step in between them
and their counterpart
bitcoin is inevitable whether we look at
places like el salvador where the
country is plugging the entire country
into the bitcoin network or we look at
places like argentina where companies
like strike are stepping in and
providing a solution to their citizens
bitcoin is just getting warmed up
bitcoin continues to grow and the people
of argentina are proving that they need
bitcoin